[Music]
hey guys it's Jerry retro no I
introduced a trailer to a movie called
tag you know playing the game right now
so god Susan you take Jerry to be your
husband
what's the difference between
Episcopalian and Lutheran Episcopalians
don't eat fish that's pescetarian us not
a religion they're all fanatics I don't
know few you may kiss the bride
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
please tell me what's going on here our
group of friends has been playing the
same game of tag for 30 years
what for the entire month of May every
year we play tag you never know when
someone's gonna pop up congratulations
buddy you're in doing great Anna our
buddy Gary is the best that ever played
and how he wants to retire never been
tagged just saying who's it take touch
to see here we get your head
super-nice your watches I don't know how
to do that I don't wear watch time is a
construct some couples go on quizzes
some couples go camping some couples go
to strip clubs and a gangbang and this
is just what we love this is our gang
bang Wow seems like the game is really
flipped you guys connected
this game has given us a reason to be in
each other's lives think your dad what I
really wanted you to be yeah
[Music]
my dick balls
but I scream what he knows I'm lactose
intolerant onsen
[Music]